is she raised 10 kids on less than ten
thousand dollars a year that's what I'm
saying don't eat out they don't travel
they they just it's not about money she
sews their clothes she she goes in the
guard I mean and it's hard oh my God
it's hard work I was just listening I'm
gonna do an episode of wife school where
I actually go out and like look at the
children that was that children did any
of their children go through bullying or
anything like that oh her children
turned out great they're like very like
they have so many traditional skills
that are so helpful in the in the modern
world like sewing what's the outlook on
life like what experiences
experience I'll show you guys an episode
of watching yet I haven't gone yet but
yeah that's gonna be interesting but it
really showed me just like the benefits
of a traditional lifestyle and like I
always thought that you needed a certain
amount of money to raise kids but then
I'm hearing this girl saying no I just
I'll be honest if I went back to Jamaica
like where my family's from I wouldn't
be focused on no money like that because
I know that there's Riches of just the
land
[Music]
when your hair is different yeah no
she's in she's in Florida
so it's not but it's sunny in Florida
that alone is a richest
people in the UK we don't we get that
about maybe three weeks or four weeks
what does that have to do with your
spending I think yeah it's like the sun
yeah it proves her point but for example
okay if like I get what and they were
trying to say at the back that basically
what yeah Collision was trying to say
um that when you're in Jamaica that you
can grow your crops there's more like
you've got more access to Growing your
own things on your own land whereas in
London if you live in like I don't know
in the city kind of Center you can't
really grow your able to budget a bit
better whereas I feel like in London you
can budget but it might be a bit harder
right but can't you move
I mean here here it's like you couldn't
move but how many people he wants to
leave their family I don't think I just
think he's an excuse to justify if money
is not an incent like money is the
be-all like the everything when I speak
to people women especially the main
thing they talk about is money money
that's their main focus in the western
world to live outside of London yeah but
like I'm from Birmingham like if I
really wanted to I could live on 20
pound a week if I really wanted to like
it's possible but people don't want it
to be possible because they value money
over anything else but maybe have you
seen the energy prices I have seen
anything prices have got a house like
I'm not afraid of the bills there's
people on Universal Credit right now how
much are they getting about 300 to 400
pounds but there are people on universal
credit with five children and they're
happier and better yes there is
social media yeah everybody do you think
that people are happier in 2023 than
they were 100 years ago no no no okay
they were poorer 100 years ago yeah but
people were just more content with life
they had better Mr rules and princess
now we're not content with life there is
because there's no morals and principles
because modern women want everything the
expenses of running a household is
different it's not just that even the
kids
has gone up if you look at
um in the U.S they look at they measure
poverty right and they have like a
poverty rate and economists measure it
and they found that people that were
living in poverty had TVs
that's what I'm saying it's a lifestyle
yeah I mean there's people like for
example where I'm from in Morocco so
people prioritize lifestyle over family
that's that's the bottom line of it it's
true I feel like you don't want children
and have no money so you want to have
money with your children so you're
putting the money before that because
you're willing to do what do you mean
sorry you don't want children and have
no money like that's not an option for
you no yeah so that and I speak for
example because I can't put my kids
through that
what are you putting them I don't want
my kids so you need money to raise your
child basically because you always want
better for your child absolutely but how
is money better for your child I don't
get it so like because so I can answer
your questions about moral's values and
principles are more important than money
absolutely no matter and no matter what
you make and no matter what you make in
2023 you are still richer than most your
kids will be richer than most kids were
wait most kids were in all of human
history so all in all of human history
the kids didn't they didn't turn out
horrible they weren't traumatized I mean
this trauma [__] this is like the last
10 15 20 years people didn't like that
was for me wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait that was for people that came
back from war
it wasn't for your ex-boyfriend cheated
on you five times
yeah but also I feel like going back to
that point
um you could I I feel like I could be
the best mother I could raise my kids
with you know the best morals and you
know
all of that right and if I do not have
money to give my son he could go out and
steal he could go you could give your
son all the money in the world and you
can still steal he couldn't go outside
to stab somebody because I could not
afford to give myself
you know you're just proving her no
because wait wait you're just proving
her point because she's saying that it's
about morals and values
and you're going back to you're proving
your point because you're saying notes
about money she's saying no it's about
worlds and values then you say no it's
about money because if we don't have
money he's gonna steal and she says no
it's about morals and values but she's
saying and I'm saying back to that that
I could bring him up with the best
Smalls ever I could be like listen we
are this kind of conditioner you can
swing that every direction
he could still steal because it happens
let me finish when he is seeing other
children with iPhones and nice nice
trainers and these things and he comes
home and I as his mother I cannot afford
to buy him that phone I can't afford to
pay his phone bill he is going to go
down the wrong path give all these guys
who are in gangs and are banged up they
come from broken homes the majority of
them come from broken homes giving your
child everything financially yes
I'm not about spoiling them I personally
believe yes a child has his own has his
or her own mind by a certain age no and
they're going to be whoever they want to
be based on what you put into them
that's fine yeah but they have their own
mind but I understand they're gonna
steal don't matter what background to
come criminals are from all walks of
life but they are more likely to steal
when they don't have it at home now it's
not about money it's about single parent
homes
at single mother homes that's where most
criminals come from yes yes yeah single
parents at homes and and they come from
broken homes it's from women's poor
decisions yes
important decisions some of them have
abusive dads some of them have okay
alcoholic dads I mean the list goes up
so it was the choice to have a child
with an alcoholic dad but you don't
sometimes always do that you
cannotically yeah
it was your choice not to bet him enough
before you had a kid with him what do
you mean no you've had an experience
happening
something someone dies in his family or
he loses his mind
you can pick you could pick someone that
doesn't drink no okay well I'm gonna go
out and ask for someone hold on hold on
you see the Kardashians who was the one
that went yeah
everything and everything in life is
your own fault no if I understand your
decision
[Applause]
whose fault is it no one ever wanted to
pick shoes whose fault is it then the
out your outcomes in life whose fault
are they hours that all four so if you
pick bad men or you pick a man that
doesn't stick around whose fault is that
I was but it's not always or if the
person no you can't say it is
if you have a bad judging character
whose fault is that
I don't think I don't that we spoke
about it before people change so that's
irresponsible for them to say but he's
saying but like you have to leave people
change so you can't say that okay like
for example yeah you still meet someone
and they're not an alcoholic and they
become one but it's still your choice
you've got to take accountability you
choose that one thing I understand
so if you could look at their family and
think Hmm his dad's an alcoholic his
grandpa even if the person changes yeah
even if the person changes you still
have to sit down and take responsibility
if that person for example um if that
person does change you can say okay I
made this choice that was my choice I
get that however people don't like I
said people change so if I've chose this
person beginning and everything but you
still got a statement I checked yeah I
will take responsibility at that time
like I've chosen this person they've
changed they've now walked out of my
child's life that's my error because I I
didn't see my fault I didn't see the
signs from the beginning maybe they
weren't there but it's my error I get
that you can take accountability however
you can't sometimes you can't see it
from the start because it's not there
but it's still it's still your respect
it's still responsibility when it
happens not you can't just say so it's
still a poor choice
I'll be real because life life events
changes people so say for example their
mum might have done and that was their
close shooting the person that actually
they could talk to and in tune with them
that could just throw them off do you
know what I mean
we're not looking at the people that
have entire midlife crisis
in general yes your choices are your
fault your outcomes it depends on the
surface if you pick a guy that can't get
through the mother of his his mother
dying that's how you meant to know that
though how
of single mothers like there are warning
signs there are warning signs you know
it they know it there was that I don't
know about that I don't know I don't
know about that I think that's a bit
that's a bit biased to be fair because
I just think it's
past Behavior yeah that's how our brain
works like it's how it's literally all
of work for all of human so time like
your brain goes off of I think women
live in a state of denial and like
that's where there's a problem you can
look at his parents like did he did he
have a stable family to look up to like
there are warning signs I do agree with
that point but even if there's warning
signs or if there isn't likely happen
whatever happens happens it's still your
choice regardless of what the the past
is you can judge the past and still get
it wrong it's still your fault it's your
life sometimes in life you take hours
and yeah yeah you still still your fault
you took the L yeah and I think when
you're in denial you create a bigger
Mess by being in denial of your I mean
it's easier to take accountability so
that was my fault and think what can I
learn from this keep moving you're never
going to learn if it's not your fault
yeah yeah well then that would make her
the person like pick a better partner I
guess yeah yeah if you take
accountability but if you say oh people
change there was no warning signs then
you're going to make the same mistake
again and again and then you're going to
keep blaming everybody out and that's
where women get bitter and say men are
trash but it's not that's why I said in
the beginning of the podcast maybe
sometimes you need to look in yourself
like to see what you can fix within
yourself by being more accountable I do
agree with that actually yeah yeah true
hear that still and this is why I say
red flags are very important take and
leave it literally but maybe sometimes
[Laughter]
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible